20:17 will be remembered as one of the
best years for games but we also had
great tech and hardware launches new
consoles changed the way we play and a
resurgence of competition in the PC
hardware market gave us more performance
for our dollars so let's look back at
the nine biggest hardware launches of
the year
Nintendo tried something risky with its
console handheld hybrid and boy did it
pay off the switch can be played like a
traditional console on a TV when it's
docked but taking top notch games on the
go is really something special by nature
of the tablet design it doesn't pack the
most powerful specs but the quality of
games like Zelda breath of the wild and
Super Mario Odyssey proves that you
don't need the best graphics to make the
best games there's something truly
amazing about being able to play these
games on the big screen in the living
room and then picking up where you left
off later on the bus now if you want the
most power out of a gaming console
Microsoft's Xbox 1x largely lived up to
the hype at $500 it's relatively
expensive in the console space but it
can give a significantly more expensive
PC a run for its money
in terms of performance that six
teraflop number thrown around translates
into much higher resolutions and more
detail and games that are enhanced for
the Xbox one X Gears of War 4 and halo 5
look better than ever running at 4k and
multi-platform games like Assassin's
Creed origins and Middle Earth shadow of
war look best on the 1x NVIDIA GTX 1080
was the fastest graphics card we have
ever tested when it debuted in 2016 but
it was overtaken by the gtx 980ti this
year it's still based on the same Pascal
architecture of the other GTX 10 series
cards but it features more cuda cores
texture units and video RAM all these
enhancements make it the fastest
consumer-level graphics card and the
best option for maxing out PC games at
4k the weight for Vega meme is dead AMD
inserted itself back into the
conversation when it comes to high-end
video cards with the rx Vegas 64 finally
an answer to NVIDIA GTX 1080 according
to our tests Vegas 64 runs slightly
better at 4k than the GTX 1080 and it
did so for $50 less when it launched at
500 bucks
AMD's more affordable RX vega 56 was a
response to the gtx 1070 in terms of
specs Vega
the six is a toned down version of the
Vegas 64 both cards use the same
architecture but the 56 featured less
stream processors texture units and a
slightly lower clock speed across the
board the card is great for 1440p
resolutions and bested in videos GTX and
70 and many of our tests AMD made a
comeback in the CPU space as well when
it released the rise in series rise in
seven topic consumer level options with
the 1,800 X 1,700 X and 1700 models all
of which are 8 core 16 thread CPUs using
the new Zen architecture the mid-range
rise and 5 family of CPUs soon followed
with the 1600 X and 1600 that packed six
cores and twelve threads the 1500 X and
1400 models offered four cores and eight
threads at the entry level
Rison three CPUs gave you quad-core
processors for cheap AMD was able to
pair multi-core performance previously
reserved for workstation CPUs and
unprecedented value Intel also came out
strong this year with their own family
of new CPUs the eighth generation of
core CPUs release in October with the i7
8700 K leading the charge for the first
time in the Intel Core lineup the
flagship consumer-level model increased
its core count going from 4 to 6 until
gave a boost to the mid-range Core i5
lineup as well going from the
traditional four core set up to a six
core setup but without multi-threading
regardless the i5 8600 K and i-5 8400
offered high-end performance at an
affordable price with the core i3 family
gone are the days of settling for a
dual-core processor when you're on a
budget now that these come with four
cords Nintendo did nostalgia right with
the SNES classic this year a follow up
to the NES classic that came before it
this cute rendition of the original SNES
packed 21 great games from the consoles
time in the early to mid 90s Super Mario
RPG Super Metroid Super Mario World and
earthbound can be played on modern TVs
with ease Star Fox 2 even got an
official release through the SNES
classic if you're using one of the older
DS models or you're interested in
jumping in the expansive library of 3ds
games we highly recommend the new 2d s
XL that came out this year it ditches
the 3d capabilities and adopts the
clamshell design it's got a sleep
minimalist look and packs the enhanced
hardware of the new 3ds models
it's Nintendo's best dia system yet and
despite the platform's age there's still
a lot to enjoy here for several years 4k
TVs have been quite expensive but TCL's
55 p 607 proved that you can get an
excellent yet affordable 4k TV in
addition to giving you ultra-high
definition the TV does HDR which makes
colors more vibrant and lighting more
realistic to top it off it's a smart TV
that comes with Roku support built right
in and only costs around 600 bucks those
were the biggest hardware releases we
saw in 2017 now if we missed anything
let us know in the comments be sure to
check out all our videos and articles
that look back at the world of games at
2017 thanks for watching and I'll see
you soon
[Music]
you